barbados se convierte en república el 30
de noviembre marca la fecha en la que la
isla da el último paso para
desvincularse de la corona británica el
día llega después de cerca de 400 años
de que el primer barco inglés llegará a
este territorio y así busca dejar atrás
su pasado colonial al celebrar este día
trascendental les envío a ustedes ya
todos los habitantes de barbados mis más
cálidos deseos de felicidad paz y
prosperidad en el futuro la isla
caribeña se independizó en 1966 del
reino unido- volviéndose una monarquía
parlamentaria un sistema político en el
que mantenía a la reina isabel como jefa
de estado haciendo parte de la comunidad
de naciones una organización compuesta
por más de 50 países que comparten lazos
con reino unidos en la misma fecha pero
55 años después barbados se convierte
así en la república más joven del mundo
y tendrá a una mujer como presidenta
elegida el pasado octubre
su nombre es andra manson fue la primera
mujer admitida en el colegio de abogados
de barbados jueza y gobernadora
encargada de crear un nuevo rumbo para
la isla mansión
pous el manto del liderazgo recae
totalmente en las generaciones de
barbadenses posteriores a la
independencia son esas generaciones las
que deben definir como nuestro país y
nuestros ciudadanos dominarán el
escenario mundial crearán una nueva
visión y construirá en el futuro de
barba
tras años de pedir un gobierno propio
este tendrá que hacerle frente a una
crisis económica agravada por la
pandemia del cob y 19 que llevó a la
disminución del turismo